- Thank you so much for joining us
for Afghanistan's Future:
Development, The State and
The Humanitarian Challenge.
This is the 11th in the series
The Yale Development Dialogues,
which are virtual panel discussions
hosted by Yale's Economic Growth Center,
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
and History Department.
I'm Catherine Cheney,
I'm a senior reporter at Devex,
focused on technology and
innovation in global development,
and I'm thrilled to moderate this series.
The Yale Development Dialogues,
for those of you who aren't familiar,
brings together perspectives from history,
economics and policy to discuss
ways to address challenges
facing low and middle income countries.
And today we're joined by experts
who have been at the forefront
of policy in Afghanistan
over the past two decades.
So I have a number of
questions I'd like to ask them,
but for those of you joining us here
live on the zoom webinar,
we really encourage you
to submit your questions
via the Q&A function.
So keep those coming throughout
and I'll get to them as soon as I can.
So transitioning to the
topic we're discussing today,
the American withdrawal from Afghanistan
left the international
community uncertain,
not only in terms of the
future of the country
and its people,
women and girls in particular,
but also the future of intervention.
So today we'll be asking questions like,
how does the situation in Afghanistan
fit into a history of many failed,
and some productive interventions?
What should the priorities
of the international
development community be
as they interact with the country now,
especially as the country faces
a real humanitarian crisis?
And what does the future hold
for the reconstruction of Afghanistan
and its relationship with
the same foreign powers
who were previously invaders?
So joining us to discuss
these questions and more,
we're thrilled to be
joined by Dr. Orzala Nemat,
an Afghan scholar and think tank leader,
who is Research Associate
at the Department of Development Studies,
which is part of the School of
Oriental and African studies
in the UK.
Khalid Payenda,
who served as the last Minister of Finance
in the Islamic Republic of Afghanistan,
leading an ambitious
portfolio of economic reforms
and anti-corruption initiatives
until his resignation in August, 2021.
And Rory Stewart, Senior Fellow
at Yale's Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs,
who served as the UK Secretary of State
for International Development.
His work focuses on
contemporary politics in crisis
and on international
development and intervention
in fragile and conflict-affected states.
And he's written
extensively on Afghanistan.
Rory's also a co-organizer of this event,
the Yale Development Dialogue series,
and he spent a lot of time in Afghanistan,
from his solo walk across
the country in 2002
to his work starting and running
the Turquoise Mountain Foundation,
to his role in government in the UK.
And Rory,
I know you've been involved
in a number of conversations
on Afghanistan recently.
I've reviewed many of them
in preparation for this discussion.
So I mentioned earlier the
Yale Development Dialogues
is unique in terms of the
interdisciplinary perspectives
it brings together.
So I'd love to hear,
what are some of your thoughts and goals
for this particular conversation?
What can our audience expect?
- Thank you very, very much indeed.
And it's great to be here
and a great privilege to be
with my two Afghan colleagues
who I hope are going to be doing
the majority of the talking.
Let me just try to frame it slightly
from a Yale University point of view
in the history of
international development.
So Afghanistan is both a
very exceptional situation,
but also one that connects
to a much, much broader, longer history.
So in terms of exception,
people will think about it
as a military intervention,
but it was also one of
the largest development,
international development
and humanitarian exercises,
of the last 20 years.
This was a country in which
the international community
didn't only deploy nearly a
million military personnel
over the period,
but hundreds of thousands of civilians
who worked with Afghan partners
on almost every dimension
of economic development.
On human rights, on civil society,
on schooling, on health,
with absolutely unparalleled
levels of investment.
Now, as with any of these situations,
it is possible to criticize
a lot of that investment.
Of course, much of the
money which was spent
by the international
community in Afghanistan
ended up finding its way back to the West
through strange contracts.
There was also of course,
a lot of corruption.
Nevertheless, there are
very, very few countries
in the world over the last 20 years
where quite so much was invested.
And there was a very, very ambitious idea
on remodeling a society.
So it gives us an opportunity to see what,
with all the ideas of the West,
all the technology of the West
all the money of the West,
what was and was not achieved
over a 20 year period
and how that compares to the way
we thought about international development
from the 1950s onwards.
And now of course, we find
ourselves in a new challenge,
which is the Taliban
government has taken over.
People are trying to put pressure
on the Taliban government
and use development and
humanitarian assistance as leverage
potentially over the Taliban government
at a time when there is an
extreme humanitarian crisis
and Afghans are now facing starvation
in some parts of the country.
So it then raises a
second series of questions
on the way in which we think
about international
development in the future.
So on that,
I'm going to step aside for a bit
and maybe hand back to my
Afghan colleagues to speak.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Rory.
And I apologize for some background noise,
unavoidable background
noise on my end here
that will hopefully subside shortly.
But one of the things that,
Khalid mentioned in
preparation for this call
was the importance of
beginning our conversation
with what was achieved.
While we're tasked with
talking about the future,
it is important to highlight
what the 20 year intervention achieved.
So I wonder if you could
expand on that point.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
It's a privilege to be here.
Greetings to the esteemed panelists
and also the moderator
and the participants
who've joined us online.
I wouldn't spend a lot of time,
I think Rory beautifully
covered a part of it.
You know, unprecedented amount of aid
flowing into our country,
but it also achieved a lot.
In the wake of the tragedy
that we've seen over the last 90 days,
it's difficult to get the
perspective of 20 years,
but a lot was achieved, you know.
Going from a GDP per capita of below $200
to tripling it over the
first decade and a half.
Having 9 million children
go back to school, you know,
more than 30, 35% of them girls.
Improvements on other
socioeconomic indicators,
you know, plummeting
maternal mortality numbers
which were the worst in the world.
Building institutions that were still,
people complaining about,
but providing some service
deliveries, you know.
People making a nine, 10 hour trip
all the way to the border to Pakistan
just to make a call to
a relative in the US.
And the West could now have social media
and telecommunication, you know,
and mobile at their fingertips.
Afghanistan connected with
multiple flights a day
flying out of Kabul.
A lot of key infrastructure built
that enabled integration
of the country better,
but also enabled better
regional connectivity.
Had it been for better
relationships with the neighbors,
that key infrastructure
could have done even much more.
So a lot was achieved.
Obviously, with the
amount of money flowing
with little accountability,
with systems that were to be built,
obviously they were misused
and were sometimes unfortunately,
with good intentions,
wastages that could have been avoided,
but a lot was achieved.
I say this and I wanted
for us to start with,
because in 2001, we faced
a similar situation.
I think it's an incredibly,
incredibly difficult
people for the whole nation,
but keeping a long-term
perspective helps, you know,
having the faith that
things could be better.
I'll stop here.
- Absolutely.
No, I appreciate you, you know,
starting us off with that
important perspective.
And zooming in on one example of progress,
Orzala, I know you have over
two decades of experience
in development practice and
promoting women's rights
in war-affected societies.
So I wonder if you can expand on the gains
for Afghan women and girls
over the past two decades,
and then we can talk
about where we are now.
- Thank you very much Catherine.
It's a great honor and pleasure
to be part of this distinguished panel,
and joining Rory and Khalid and yourself
into this discussion.
Very crucial and timely, I would say.
With regards to gains of
the last twenty years,
before even starting to talk about gains
we have to sort of keep in mind
that the gains come with
a lot of troubles as well.
Generally speaking,
and specifically with regards to women.
So I just sort of divide the gains
in terms of social,
political and economic.
And very briefly, run through
all of it just for us,
for our sort of memories,
to remind ourselves of
what has been the changes.
In the social field,
what we see have been
achieved is a massive and...
excuse me, there was an annoying sound,
I hope you now don't hear it.
My notebook was getting somewhere.
- [Catherine] Our fault.
- I hope now it's clearer.
So in terms of social gains,
what I'd like to highlight
is this change in people,
particularly, generally in Afghanistan,
in rural Afghanistan
in terms of people's behaviors
towards women's rights,
women's position in society.
There has been some unprecedented
level of achievements
in the rural and community
development side of things.
In some communities and in some areas
that I have gone because
of my own research
on local power relations
and local governance,
I find out that for the first time
in the history of these areas,
the state and the donors
have reached there
not to extract, but to deliver.
So this is something that we cannot deny.
Nobody, including the Taliban,
cannot deny the impact of
the community development.
And the role of women in the
community development programs.
The conditionality that was set up
has been a game changer.
Now, having said that,
in terms of social behavioral
change has happened.
We see a thirst for education.
We see that thirst for
education across the country,
across generations, across gender.
There is a pin pad campaign by volunteers
from the Southern Afghanistan,
running around with the
men that in appearance
to all internationals look like a Taliban,
no different from a Taliban.
Long beard, big turban,
having a paper,
a placard in their hand that says
open the schools for girls.
So that's something that
has a message for everyone,
particularly for those who
are ruling the country now.
The political games,
although in many aspects quite symbolic,
but has been also important.
We've had in the constitution 25% quotas,
but a lot of women made
it beyond that quota
in the provincial council
and parliamentary elections.
So the symbolic part aside,
and the political reason,
some of the behaviors of the politicians
using instrumentally
women position was there,
but women themselves have created
an identity for themselves
to be very particular.
Not necessarily representing themselves
as the representatives
of the Western values
or Eastern values or anything.
Very pure, very traditional,
but at the same time
very aware and conscious of their rights.
I think these are critical.
And just very quickly,
I know I've gone beyond my two minutes,
but just very quickly,
in terms of economic gains as well,
we have to remember 70%
of Afghan population
lives in rural areas,
but the economic gains has
also been quite significant
in the rural context
where women were able to access markets,
sell their products to the
level possible, obviously,
and I'm just worried what
will happen to it now.
Women were able to make,
to be involved in businesses,
small, medium, and larger scales,
more in the small and medium range.
Less in larger, because of course,
the men are trying to sort of,
men earn more over them.
So overall, in all these
different sort of areas
there has been quite significant gains
that we cannot deny it.
And that's something
that with the crisis that is happening now
may be affected.
Maybe we will see the different levels
and maybe we'll see some changes,
but there will not be a kind of a dragging
to the zero point again.
That's my sort of,
bit of an optimism in terms
of moving way forward.
Thanks.
- Thank you.
Rory, please jump in.
- A couple of quick things.
I mean, I think the
first thing to understand
is that the story in Afghanistan is uneven
depending upon which part
of the country you're talking about.
So in many ways there was huge progress,
not just in urban areas.
Obviously in places that the cities,
but also in places like the
Bamiyan Valley, Hazarajat,
extraordinary transformation
over 20 years.
Other areas of the country, for example,
the Sangin district in Helmand.
Very, very difficult.
And in some ways the lives
of women in those communities
didn't change as much
as we would have liked
over the period.
Partly because they were in the middle
of a horrible conflict.
Drug wars, warlords,
and ultimately a Taliban insurgency.
On the second point
that Dr. Orzala has made
about small businesses,
this is absolutely vital.
And there's actually a great deal
the international
community can do to help.
At the moment there are
nearly a million Afghan women
working in the carpet industry,
and that industry has amazing potential.
You don't need to think about it,
as it might've been in the past,
as a place which was dominated
by minimum wages and child labor.
We were beginning,
in the last couple of years,
to secure some very high value
contracts for Afghan carpets,
selling to big American and
European buyers and suppliers,
setting up good weaving workshops
with good conditions for
children and creches.
And actually, as Turkey and India
moves out of the handmade carpet industry,
that could be a huge
opportunity for Afghans
to generate small and
medium size enterprises.
The problem is that the
international community now
is not putting any more investment.
USAID said it's not going to support
the export industry anymore.
Everybody's saying
we're just going to think
about humanitarian support,
and this is classified
as development support.
And this will mean,
very unnecessarily and cruelly,
that these great export opportunities,
these contracts that women
have managed to secure
with huge difficulty,
are now under threat
from the international community itself,
often for quite unconvincing reasons
to do with unrealistic views
of how they can leverage the Taliban.
- I think that's a great example.
When it comes to questions,
we'll get to around to the role
of the international development
community in Afghanistan.
Some of the decisions
being made are hampering
some potential progress here,
for example, in the carpet industry,
really interesting.
I wanted to talk about the withdrawal
and certainly make sure we talk about that
before we look at the current state
of the country and the future.
So you know, as I mentioned earlier,
the dramatic collapse of the military
and takeover by the Taliban
really left the international
community uncertain
about not just the future of the country,
but the future of intervention.
And Rory,
I know as you and I discussed
the framing of this event,
we wanted to talk not just about
Afghanistan and its future,
which is our main task,
but also how this fits into
a history of interventions.
And that speaks to the spirit
of the Yale Development
Dialogues, weaving in history.
So can you expand on that?
Just kind of putting this
into larger historical context
and then I'd love to see
if our other panelists
have additional thoughts.
- Yeah,
so essentially Afghanistan
was the last big intervention
in a 20 year period of intervention,
which started with Bosnia and Kosovo,
which actually gave
quite a lot of confidence
to the international community
because in Bosnia and Kosovo,
essentially there was an intervention,
it was largely peaceful, a war ended.
There was no insurgency
and progress was made.
And that in a sense
drove some of the investment
into Iraq and Afghanistan,
which of course were the
two later interventions.
In the case of Afghanistan itself
there were three distinct phases.
There was an initial phase
of quite a light footprint,
very few troops not doing very much.
Then the international community
got dragged into doing
more and more and more
because they felt that the situation
in 2001, 2005 was not satisfactory.
And then they went back to
a light footprint again.
The issue however,
is that the lesson that will
be taken from Afghanistan
is not actually the points
that Khalid or Dr. Orzala have made
about how much was achieved.
In the United States and
in Europe, unfortunately,
people are convincing themselves
that nothing was achieved,
that the whole thing was a mess.
Which is completely not true.
I mean, for any of us who saw Afghanistan
at the end of the Taliban period,
the difference between then
and 2021 was unbelievable.
I mean, Kabul was a ghost
town at the end of 2001.
You know, when I walked
from Herat to Kabul
there was no electricity
for 350 miles in 2001.
I mean, it's a totally different country.
But we need to start
rebuilding some confidence
amongst the international community
that something can be achieved.
And it's about getting out
of a black and white mindset.
Of course,
we've proved that you can't build
a perfect nation under fire,
but that doesn't mean that
you can't do anything.
That doesn't mean that the whole project
of international development
is a waste of time
or there's nothing that you can do.
Of course there's
corruption, there's waste,
but I think Khalid really
put his finger on it
in putting that in context.
Explaining yes, those things happen.
They don't just happen in Afghanistan.
They happen in Sub-Saharan Africa.
They happen in Myanmar.
They happen in many places
and things can go wrong.
But when things go wrong,
when the Taliban takes over,
don't conclude from that,
that that is because all Afghans
want a Taliban government.
That's the other mistake
that people are making.
The Taliban didn't come into these towns
with everybody waving flags
saying welcome the Taliban, right?
This is an armed jihadist group.
They were not elected.
And Afghan's been fighting for 20 years
and ultimately people
chose not to commit suicide
trying to fight the Taliban,
but that doesn't mean that
they've chosen the Taliban.
And that doesn't mean
that Afghans as a whole
think that the last 20
years was a waste of time
and they prefer the situation
they have at the moment.
- Absolutely.
Khalid or Orzala, you
wanna jump in on that?
- Yeah. I second everything Rory said,
including his last intervention
on the differences in how
intervention was done within provinces.
It also had to do a lot with
winning hearts and minds.
Somehow military did not do
what militaries do, you know.
They went and created parallel structures,
dwarfing the other institutions
that were supposed to
do aid work, you know.
The US military spending in some years,
a hundred times more on development,
then USA is going to skew
the whole development agenda.
And unfortunately you know,
the size of the national
budget was so small
and so much was spent outside the budget
that the government had
a real problem, you know,
showing and increasing its legitimacy.
And so these things really did have a role
in how things played.
And unfortunately, you know,
when you look at some of the lessons
that come out of Afghanistan.
it's not the first time, you know.
If you look at aid
effectiveness principles
of what you should do and don't,
and how you expand and
what channels you use
and how the government could be a partner,
unfortunately not much has been learned.
There is a lot of lessons
that are reiterated
from Afghanistan that should be learned,
but then I'm not very optimistic
about the behavior of these
international institutions
and learning those those
lessons from Afghanistan
for hopefully, you know,
improved intervention in Afghanistan
from now on or somewhere else.
- Orzala,
anything to add in terms of lessons
that should have been
learned to inform, you know.
- Yes.
- Had lessons from history
been considered, perhaps,
things would have unfolded differently
and/or lessons that we
should be taking now from,
you know, the crisis that has unfolded
to inform work, moving forward.
- Thank you Catherine,
adding to things that have been mentioned,
I think Afghanistan,
in terms of many fields,
whether international relations
or even many other economics, whatever,
particularly including I would say,
development studies field,
I think it's a case study
in all different ways.
So in that sense,
my hope and desire is
to see all, you know,
educational institutions
globally across the world
in the developing world,
but also in the developed world,
they have to pick Afghanistan
and study each and every project
and program interventions.
And there is a tremendous
amount of lessons to be learned
in all of it.
I go about some general lessons learned
because I'm sure you know,
Yale, and the politics department
and everything can get it
sort of to higher up.
I think one of the biggest lessons
that the intervening forces need to learn
is to stop investing on individuals.
We started with making Karzai
the most well-dressed man of the year.
And we ended up with
calling him, I don't know,
all kinds of,
a man with all kinds of illnesses
and schizophrenic and whatever.
We started, Ashraf Ghani,
with calling him the
second thoughtful man.
I don't know how to translate
that back into English,
but Theorist in Chief,
I looked up in Google.
You know, he was...
- The second cleverest
man in the world, we said.
- Something like that, right?
So we call him,
the New York,
New Yorker actually,
call him the Theorist in Chief
and then, look at what happened, right?
So stop investing on individuals
when you intervene in a country.
It will end up in a disaster, as it did.
The other biggest lesson,
I think to go very broadly,
is the issue of donor dependency.
The starvation that Rory
was mentioning before,
the situation, the catastrophe
that we are facing now,
it's quite shocking in fact,
if you think about it.
One in two people don't know
where the next food is coming from.
And I literally witnessed
that on a daily basis
dealing with my own friends
and relatives and colleagues.
This is the depth of the crisis.
You cannot put this all on a government
or a failed government or one party.
I think from United Nations to World Bank
to all the donor conferences
and fancy, you know,
reports and everything,
everyone should question themselves,
why we led everything to
this level of dependency.
And last but not least,
one other part that I would like to go on
is aggressive means always fail.
The whole of war on terror was a failure,
we have to note that.
The whole mission was
to go and "smoke out",
quote, unquote, the terrorists.
Guess what?
Those you call terrorists
are handed over back the whole country on.
We don't go into blaming game here,
but aggressive means,
Guantanamo Bay, drone attacks,
night raids, didn't work.
And that's what we see.
The Taliban are more aggressive
today because of those,
they are reacting against the actions
that were taken against them.
So I think these are key lessons
that we need to sort of
look into stopping here.
- Rory, go ahead.
- One thing I would add is
the international community
being modest and humble with itself
and with others about what it can achieve.
One of the problems is
that when you're spending,
and when I was Secretary of State
for International Development
I felt this pressure,
you're spending billions of dollars
in somebody else's country.
So there's a lot of
pressure to tell the voters
in Europe or the United States
that we're going to transform everything.
And you also are always
showing off towards Afghans,
telling them, "It's all going to be great,
we know what we're doing.
We have best practice, capacity building,
it's all going to be amazing."
It would be very helpful to,
from the beginning,
set more realistic expectations.
The truth is the history of
international development
in a country with a lot of
challenges like Afghanistan,
and as Khalid has pointed out,
this was one of the poorest
countries in the world in 2001.
We had a situation where
many villages in 2001,
there was only maybe one or
two people in the whole village
who could read or write, right?
And it's almost impossible to know
what the infant mortality rate was
because there was no proper registration
of births and deaths under the Taliban,
but we know it was terrible, right?
So if you're starting from that level
to be very realistic with Afghans
and with your own voters
about what you can achieve.
So instead of saying,
we're going to create,
and this is something we all did,
British politicians did it,
but Afghan politicians did it too.
You know, Ashraf Ghani,
I remember when I saw him
at the beginning of 2002
saying we're gonna create
a gender-sensitive,
multi-ethnic, centralized state
based on democracy, human rights,
rule of law, right?
It's not very helpful.
Of course, maybe that's the long-term aim
but begin by saying our
aim is over 10 or 20 years
to make Afghanistan more prosperous,
improve the schools, improve the clinics.
It's gonna be slow.
It's gonna take a lot of time.
And by building that spirit,
you're not going to get so
many frustrated Afghans,
you're not gonna get frustrated voters,
you're not gonna get into this crazy,
very American,
all-or-nothing mentality.
Either we throw the
entire US military at it,
or we do nothing at all, right?
This doesn't work domestically.
If you were working with a,
I don't know,
a community in the United
States with high unemployment,
let's say a coal community
in East Kentucky.
You wouldn't think that
it makes sense to say,
we're gonna go and we're
gonna to fix everything
and we're going to do
it by dumping, you know,
a hundred billion dollars on you.
And then if it doesn't work
out in 10 years, we're leaving.
We've got an exit strategy,
and then we'll blame you.
We'll say you're all cowardly
and incompetent and corrupt and we're off.
Of course, partnering is a
very long, patient process.
And parts of the thing we did
is the Afghans became frustrated
because we pretended to
do things we couldn't do.
Instead of being honest from the beginning
that it was going to be messy,
that it was going to be very
long-term and getting out.
And I think Orzala was wonderful on this.
The ridiculous, you know,
hero to villain thing that
we did with the presidents,
with President Karzai
and Present Ghani, right?
Actually in many ways,
compared to presidents
and much the rest of developing world,
these were pretty good guys.
The problem was that we would
convince ourself one moment
that they were geniuses and saints,
and then the next moment we all said
that they were corrupt and incompetent.
It's a crazy way of
thinking about anything.
- Really powerful lessons
being shared here.
We have some questions coming in,
and many of these questions
are geared toward Afghanistan's future.
So I wanna make sure we
move in that direction.
But first, you know,
some of this has been brought up,
a crisis in terms of
food security, hunger,
but as we all know,
three months now into Taliban rule,
the country is really facing
a humanitarian crisis,
from its economy to
issues related to hunger.
I just wanna hear from each of you,
sort of what are your top concerns
when it comes to the
state of the country now,
and that will help us transition
into the role the international
development community
can and should play,
and perhaps what they should stop doing.
So, as was mentioned earlier,
before the Taliban takeover,
the country received an
enormous amount of foreign aid,
or as Orzala mentioned earlier,
this problem of donor dependency.
So perhaps that's something
we can bring into the
conversation as well.
Like how did the country end up here?
And it's not just the
very messy withdrawal
that is part of it,
but there are other
dynamics at play as well.
So what are your top concerns
in terms of the crisis
the country's facing now?
And then we'll get into
what the international
development community can do.
Maybe we'll start with Khalid?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So just to put it in context,
Afghanistan received 40% of,
compared to 40% of the GDP in aid.
50% of the government's
budget was financed by donors.
And that meant, you know,
in a budget where 75% of the
budget goes to operating,
you know, salaries of police
and teachers and civil service,
you know, half of it was by by donors
and everything, the same amount
was of budget, $8 billion.
Suddenly, it's like a
tap turned off overnight.
It's going to create a massive
problem, and it already has.
And on top of it,
you have a banking sector that
you rely on more and more,
not for lending normal banking
because we had issues in that area,
but for transfers.
So the meager savings that people had,
the equivalent to a few hundred dollars
were stuck in banks that they
could not access for weeks.
And it created a massive problem,
massive problem in urban centers,
which was already seeing
higher levels of poverty levels
than rural sectors,
because they were dependent
more on the government than others.
So my biggest concern is the famine.
In June and July, I was
still at the government.
We launched a humanitarian appeal,
a joint one with the UN,
because we were facing
problems with drought,
problems with displacement
and problems with COVID.
The third wave of COVID was very harsh
and it had meant that
12 to 18 million people,
half of the population then,
were at the risk of it.
And now you add on top of it
the sudden reduction or stoppage of aid,
that's a huge catastrophe.
My biggest concern is
that I don't see, unfortunately,
the urgency from
international organizations.
Everybody's looking to the US treasury
and the US treasury does
not either care or answer
or they're afraid of Biden
because he does not want
to hear Afghanistan's name,
to put it very bluntly.
And other international organizations,
because they have powerful governors
of the US government
sitting on their boards,
they're all paralyzed, you know.
The World Bank sits on the
biggest trust fund in the world
for Afghanistan.
Afghanistan reconstruction trust fund,
you have to just convert
the ordinary construction
into relief and you know,
reprogram some of them,
but it's not happening.
My concern is,
taking time on this when we
are approaching the winter
is going to cause massive human suffering,
maybe something that we haven't seen,
at least not this century,
maybe in the last 40, 50 years.
35 million people,
where UN is projecting 97% poverty
by the end of this year,
that's unheard of anywhere.
And you know, as somebody
who's worked in this field,
I can tell you that these
are not exaggerated numbers.
97% could be, you know,
the base case.
It could get worse than this.
I think humanitarian
aid needs to move fast.
I think the international community,
international donors,
the UN and the IFIs who've
been engaged in Afghanistan
and who've partnered
have to find a way around
the US treasury sanctions,
because those are not going
to be lifted any time soon.
If you are a realist
you have to think that.
But there are other ways,
mechanisms to swapping
and mechanisms through physical transfer
of cash into the country
to make sure that these programs go ahead.
And talking of the gains,
some of these achievements
that were made in Afghanistan
were done in collaboration
with international agencies,
but also NGOs.
The basic package of health services
was all delivered to NGOs.
The community development councils
by the sub-national levels.
You know,
you don't need to go to
a Taliban administration,
a UN agency, for example,
WHO could take over the
coordination and invoicing
and messaging oversight mechanisms
that was done by ministry
of public health,
and you could still still do this.
So my concern is humanitarian plus.
By humanitarian plus,
I mean basic services
of health and education
and community development must flow.
Otherwise, we will have
suffering at the large scale.
I think just my last point,
something that Rory alluded
to in his opening points,
you also have to understand Taliban.
Leverages like this do not work on them.
You are creating suffering
for a lot of people.
They don't care about it, you know.
They could still rule with an iron fist
for the next 20 years.
And there is a limit to how
much aid could have overall.
So please have,
look at my appeal to
international community as,
look at the bigger picture,
look at the suffering of a lot of people.
And it's not just Afghanistan,
it's going to haunt the whole world.
You know Afghanistan,
fortunately or unfortunately
will always be in headlines.
And if you leave it like
they have right now,
they think it's the end of it, it's not,
it's going to come back and bite everyone.
- So many great points
and a couple of things I want
to return to in a moment,
but I wanna bring Dr. Orzala in here.
But you mentioned it was like
turning the tap off overnight.
And as you said, it's not
just the foreign aid dollars,
but the NGOs working on the ground,
many of whom have pulled out their staff,
or are still trying to
figure out how to engage.
One of the things I
also appreciate Khalid,
in addition to just outlining
the crisis and the urgency,
you mentioned that there
are practical challenges,
but also ways to find
a way around sanctions.
And I do hope we can kind of
get into quite practically,
how does international
development community engage.
But first, Dr. Orzala,
I know you wanted to jump in,
just in terms of outlining
where the country is now.
And then we'll kind of move
into where things are headed.
- Just to add in terms of, you know,
humanitarian crisis.
The urgency is critical,
as we mentioned throughout
the conversation here.
But I liked the point Khalid
made regarding, you know,
humanitarian plus
because the goal here should
not be to keep Afghanistan.
We have a saying in Afghanistan,
that serum, you know,
you go to the doctor and immediately
he puts an injection and a serum into you.
We don't want our country,
38 million of people to become dependent
on the aid and food.
So yes, feed people now
because a terrible winter is on its way,
and people don't have enough
to keep themselves warm,
to keep their children and themselves fed.
So this is immediate emergency.
And I call not only on donors,
and organizations and government,
but also on individuals,
anyone who knows someone
in Afghanistan just should,
all you need is a bank account
and an ID from someone.
Transfer some dollars,
transfer your lunch money,
just be on a diet for one
day and get something,
send something there,
because really everyone needs it.
Even people,
I'm telling this to the
middle class type of people,
even people who had savings,
they saved a lot of money for
the future of their children,
like you all will do,
the audience of this panel.
It's all frozen in their accounts,
they cannot take it out.
So this is a kind of a human
responsibility to all of us.
The issue is that this should not be
a long-term solution.
The development assistance,
the sustainability of getting people,
Afghan people are entrepreneurs by nature.
All they need is some means.
So that should be really also critical.
To keep the development assistance,
the development aid,
the development of,
the economic development specifically
is something that we have
to think about longer-term.
I'll later probably come in
a moment on the sanctions,
but stop here, thanks.
- Yeah, we'll return to that.
Absolutely.
And the point you just made
kind of gets back to what Rory was saying
in terms of small and
medium enterprises, SMEs.
But Rory, did you want to jump in?
- I think the first thing is that I think
all of us agree that the
international community
should be generous towards Afghanistan.
And now,
that means getting humanitarian
assistance sent out,
but it also means continuing
development assistance.
Not just emergency food aid,
but the things that help
the Afghan economy grow
and help the Afghan
community support itself.
Why is it not happening?
It's not happening for
a series of reasons.
One of them, unfortunately
is there is a sense of emotional anger
and humiliation from the
international community.
So when I say on Twitter, for example,
please support Afghanistan
I get people tweeting
back saying nonsense stuff
like, "They chose the
Taliban, it's their fault.
Why should we help them now?"
So we have to be honest with people
about the fact that they're wrong
in saying that Afghans
chose the Taliban, right?
The other thing is that people believe
or are trying to convince themselves,
particularly politicians,
that somehow this is gonna give people
leverage over the Taliban.
Well, this is again wrong.
It's wrong in many ways.
As Khalid pointed out,
it just doesn't work.
Many of these Taliban fighters
have been living in very tough conditions,
in refugee camps or almost
in caves in the hills
in some situations.
They're not like Russian oligarchs.
They don't want to go shopping
in fifth avenue in Manhattan, right?
So they're not primarily motivated
by these questions around sanctions.
But there's a bigger point,
which is that actually it's morally wrong
to starve the Afghan people,
believing that by threatening
to starve the Afghan people
you're gonna somehow get
political concessions
out of the Taliban
is totally immoral.
Now, what does this mean practically?
Practically, a lot of
this is bureaucratic.
This is, why is the money stopping?
It's stopping often for
small bureaucratic reasons.
State department has suddenly
canceled a lot of its projects
because they said they
didn't have enough staff
on the ground to administer them.
European Union has
canceled a lot of projects
saying we don't do development anymore,
we're now just gonna do humanitarian.
USAID is trying to re-profile, right?
Which is a very complicated,
bureaucratic process
where they're saying
we don't want to support export industry.
It's like the carpet industry,
but we're going to go into livelihoods.
And then other people are saying,
"No, there are terrorists who
are in the Afghan government."
And that's the most dangerous thing of all
because people are
beginning to say, "No, but",
this is the sanctions people.
Let's say you export a carpet.
Let's say you pay 2% export tax
and that export tax goes
to the Afghan government,
and the Afghan government
is a Taliban government
and one of the ministers is a terrorist,
are you "funding" terrorists?
If you buy petrol in the gas station
and you pay sales tax
and that money goes to
the Afghan government
and the Afghan governments
is the Taliban government,
and a member of the cabinet's a terrorist,
are you "funding" terrorim?
So the international community
needs to be clear and practical
and take a little bit of risk
and make some decisions.
And the decision has to be,
be quick, be generous,
and don't get caught up in
these problems around sanctions.
- Thank you, Rory.
We have a lot of questions
coming in from the audience,
but first I wanted to
see if Orzala or Khalid
wanted to respond to that at all?
Otherwise, I definitely have
some questions to turn to.
Go ahead, Orzala.
- I just wanted to very briefly reiterate
on the sanction point that Rory has made,
and then we can go to questions.
My personal view on the sanction situation
is that I would like
to know about a country
where sanction have achieved the goal
that the country is trying
to punish economically,
those countries have achieved.
And then I would say,
yes this is the best solution.
I mean, emotions aside,
everyone is angry and upset
in one way or another,
but here it's not about
me and what I lost.
It's about 30 million people,
6 million of whom are living in Kabul,
one of the most highly
population-concentrated cities
in the country,
and they just don't know what to do next.
The urban poverty is as much deep
and as much dangerous
as the rural poverty.
The rural is a little bit
less at risk at this time
because they have been like
going through this poverty
for a long, long time.
But even people with, as I said,
small and medium sort of
activities and enterprises
are going into crisis.
So, the question,
there has to be a distinction
between giving legitimacy to some actions
that the Taliban government are taking,
particularly their gender
apartheid at the moment,
in terms of, you know,
complete discrimination against women.
They have to really,
and just share with you,
I mean, some sort of
reflections from the ground
within the Taliban,
within the Taliban
younger generation forces,
they themselves are not convinced.
And I'm sure they're listening to me
saying that they are not convinced
with these actions of
closing girls' education.
because I'm sure their own sisters at home
are not happy with this decision.
If their sisters are living
in Afghanistan at the moment,
which I'm sure for some
of them it's the case.
If they are in the middle
of their universities,
they cannot attend the universities,
they are also not confident.
And they're already,
like somebody was sharing on social media,
a picture of a drive-through
which shows girls going to school
and immediately one of the young Taliban
tweeted in Arabic and says,
this is rumors against the Taliban
that girls are not
letting to go to school,
here, look, they are going to school.
And that guy again, corrected himself,
says no, this is primary school,
these are not children.
These are not secondary and high school
and university students,
girls are still not going.
So scholars,
Islamic scholars from around the world
called on Taliban and says,
can you come into a conversation with us
so that we can resolve this?
My view is that the
issue of girls education
is not related to international
lobbying and advocacy.
I think the people of
Afghanistan themselves
will manage their way to convince Taliban
to move on from this very
illogical sort of step
to keep girls away from education
and to keep women away from work.
Practically sector by sector,
we observe some flexibility.
Health sector was first.
They never had restrictions on
doctors attending the clinics
or nurses,
but slowly vaccination, slowly others.
So there has to be ongoing engagement.
Dehumanization has not
worked, will not work.
So there has to be ongoing engagement.
Sanctions from the global,
from international point of view
is completely problematic as an Afghan.
I think it's extremely problematic
in that the harm of it will
go to the average Afghan
living in Zabul, Oruzgan, you know,
Nuristan, Kunar,
everywhere in the country,
or Hazarajat, everywhere basically.
It will not affect the Taliban,
It will not,
because let's not forget the role
of illicit economy in the country.
Other secondary sources
that are not on the record,
but still feed very well this
kind of government and systems
and those in power.
- Orzala, I wanna bring in one question
from the audience for you.
And you may have just touched on this,
but in case there's anything to add,
the question is,
what is your outlook
regarding women and
girls under the Taliban?
What is your biggest concern
and any ideas for solutions?
- My outlook,
despite going through a
very, very harsh situation
at the moment in terms of, you know,
women and girls' education.
And I have like hundreds
of women and girls
basically contacting me,
and I'm sure many other women leaders
at what will be the next.
I am personally optimistic
that this will be very temporary
and there will be changes
and pressure on Taliban.
I'm not necessarily talking
only about international,
international pressure
should also be consistent.
But national pressure is
consistent on Taliban,
to come into terms of allowing education,
allowing women to work
in different sectors,
and even allowing women
to work also in politics.
So the concern,
the biggest concern is to
just see some countries,
major countries with a lot
of leverage and influences,
try to just keep a close eye
on all the actions of the
Taliban at national level
and just move on by legitimizing them.
So there is a very
narrow sort of line here,
not to be crossed.
Engage yes, but not
legitimize their actions
so that they don't get overconfident
by some of the wrongdoings that they do
in terms of, you know, moving forward.
So continuous engagement
is key to move forward.
Concern is to see this falling down.
Afghanistan should
remain in conversations,
but in constructive conversations,
not really something
that will continue to
divide us and rule us.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
So speaking of this
concern of legitimizing,
there's a question here
kind of broadening the lens
in terms of the international community's
future engagement with Afghanistan.
Here's the question from our audience,
building on some of what's been discussed,
but just presenting another
opportunity to revisit this.
So the question is,
I think the appetite
for doing more development in
Afghanistan is constrained,
not by the view that we
failed in Afghanistan,
but by the argument that
offering development aid
will legitimize the Taliban government
or prop them up in some way.
She goes on to say development
aid is never neutral,
so how do we do it
ethically in this context
without being seen to,
or actually propping up
the Taliban government?
Rory?
- Well, there's no easy answers to this,
and we need to be realistic about this.
I mean, we can produce spin.
And obviously the principal needs to be,
to try to make sure that
the development and humanitarian aid
reaches ordinary Afghans
and doesn't reach the Taliban government.
But as I've tried to explain,
nothing is ever quite that simple
because if an NGO fills up
their car at a gas station,
they will pay sales tax on that.
And some of that will go
to the Taliban government.
And that is unfortunately true,
not just in Afghanistan.
It's true if you're doing
humanitarian aid in South Sudan,
it's true if you're doing
humanitarian development aid
almost anywhere around the world.
You have to make difficult
compromises with the government.
The leverage though that
we should be exercising
of the Taliban government,
is around diplomatic recognition.
And maybe you could say to them,
"Look, we're going to provide
a generous level of humanitarian
and development support
to the Afghan people,
but if you want more than that,
if you want diplomatic recognition,
if you want more of these opportunities,
these are the things you have to do."
But don't use,
as I keep saying,
starving people as a way
of trying to threaten
the Taliban government,
it's not going to work.
They're not going to pay any attention.
It hasn't worked anywhere in the world.
It's a very, very mad thing to do.
And remember,
above all, what that will
mean is if you do this,
if the Taliban government
finally goes in 20 years' time,
Afghans will be very, very rightly angry
with the international community.
If you want to have a good
relationship with Afghanistan,
you're not going to achieve it
by starving the people and
pretending that by doing so,
you're going to change the
behavior of the Taliban.
- Thanks, Rory.
And building on that question,
there's another question here
that I'd love for Khalid
to jump in and answer.
And the question is,
are there practical ways the West
can engage with the Taliban
without invoking feelings of
negotiating with terrorists?
So kind of building on what
Rory just responded to,
but Khalid I think you could respond
to this specifically.
- I completely second
Rory on this part as well.
But as he said,
there are no easy straightforward answers.
But what's the alternative?
The alternative of shutting them off
and doing no engagement.
You don't use any of the
leverages that you have, you know.
So then you also play into the hands
of the hardliners within Taliban.
And they would say, you know,
these Westerners, these infidels,
you know, they are never straight.
And look what they've done.
You are providing a breeding ground
for future generations of terrorists,
or even people who are angry.
Angry at the West of being betrayed
and left alone.
So I think engagement on humanitarian plus
should be a gateway for
further discussions.
I think they've shown some
willingness on discussions
on girls' education, for example,
which is a welcome
improvement and development,
but more should be done.
But still,
I believe if there is the issue
of going to the Taliban government
and then financing going
to them as a concern,
there are ways, as I
said earlier you know,
you have national programs, for example,
the citizen charter
or national basic package
of health services.
You just have to replace
the government agency
that used to do the
oversight for another agency.
Well, probably UN.
UN is engaging through them.
So that's a start.
And Taliban would want
sustainability of their rule.
A very angry population is
not very conducive for that.
So they understand that.
But then there is a limit to all of this.
At what cost are we
going to isolate Taliban?
At the cost of 30 million
people starving to death?
I think it's not going to look good
on the whole Western idea
of freedom and human rights.
So you have to engage with them.
And as Rory and Orzala have mentioned,
we don't have to go far
to see for an example
of how isolation has not worked, you know.
Look at our neighboring
Iran in the last 40 years.
Crippling sanctions, you know,
for people who've been there, you know,
hyperinflation, but what has happened?
They've increased their
grasp on the system
and population more.
I think abandoning
discussions with the Taliban
might not be the right approach.
- One other question
I'd love to just squeeze
in from the audience
before coming to each of
you with final thoughts.
We've been talking about
a lot about the West
and interactions with
Afghanistan moving forward.
And there's a question
about regional politics,
neighboring countries and larger powers
like China and Russia.
So I wonder if anyone
would want to jump in
on that question.
- Maybe I could add a couple of points
before Rory and Orzala have their views.
I think you have to study
every neighbor, you know.
Pakistan has warned us.
It's something that we
haven't recognized enough
is this is a Pakistan-enabled
invasion, you know.
Regardless of what issues
we had in the government,
we had an elected government,
a democracy that was improving.
It's better than what's
happening right now, you know.
They did not want an Indian
influence and they've got it.
I don't think they want a stable,
fully stable Afghanistan either.
The status quo is the ideal situation
for ISI and Pakistan to have
in Afghanistan, you know,
as long as it's contained.
People who have a longer
view in Pakistan are worried,
and they're worried that this fanaticism
will spill over the
borders and it already has.
Russia, it was a difficult situation.
They wanted US out of the region,
but they also don't want the extremism
crossing the Amu River into
the Central Asian countries.
With China, you know,
I believe as long as it's
contained in Afghanistan,
they have access to the minerals
and the lithium and copper and all that.
That's a win for them
and for Iran as well, you know.
I think they wanted US
losing in Afghanistan,
but they want stable right now.
They want stable borders
so they could dump their low quality fuel
and other products that
they cannot do anywhere else
because of the sanctions.
With Uzbekistan and and others,
as long as they have borders and exports
and it's contained in Afghanistan,
that's fine, you know.
And there's somebody,
not a lot of them mind
the current situation,
as long as it stays in Afghanistan
and does not create bigger headaches.
But that view might be a short-term view.
The long-term unstable
Afghanistan at the heart of Asia
is not good for the whole
region, but also the whole world.
- Thank you Khalid.
Rory, did you want to
jump in on that quickly?
- No no, I'll leave you,
'cause you're heading
towards the end aren't you?
You want to do some final comments?
- Yeah, if you don't mind.
We do just have a couple minutes left.
So maybe anything you want to
note on that, we can get to.
But I just want to, as we close,
we've covered so much ground
and again,
our task today was certainly
to look at how we got here,
the state of the country currently,
but particularly Afghanistan's future.
And so I wonder,
just in our last couple minutes here,
and I hate to ask such a big question
with only about 30 seconds
left for each of you.
But you know, you've all
made so many great points.
What's one thing you want
to leave our audience with
in terms of Afghanistan's future.
A call to action,
specifically for the international
development community
which we've discussed quite a bit.
Maybe we'll start with you Orzala,
and then we'll hear from Khalid
and we'll close with Rory.
- Thank you, Catherine.
I hope to be able to say it in 30 seconds.
But my personal message to the
international development aid
and to those who are
willing to support a sponsor
is to invest on the
Afghanistan's young generation,
provide them with scholarship
opportunities now,
before it becomes too late,
particularly girls.
I am working on a personal mission on this
together with another Yale world fellow,
as we are at Yale
university I will say this,
Lorna Solis,
she's also a world's fellow
and I'm hoping to get your
support for this mission.
Starting with a small
group of young Afghan girls
and expanding it to a larger one.
The best way forward in the longer term
is to invest on young
generation scholarships
across different themes and subjects.
Not only social or political sciences,
but very critical subjects
for the future of the country.
Thank you.
- Thank you. Khalid?
- Yeah, I think act now
before six to nine months,
or even three to six months of wait,
which might be too late.
But, for my fellow Afghans,
you know, somebody who's seen it,
somebody who's been
part of this government
that has collapsed,
somebody who shares part
of the blame, you know,
I am a big critic of myself as well.
I think all hope is not lost.
We should use this to examine
the things that went wrong.
If we have a better
opportunity in the future,
what sort of democracy would be built.
Something that's built
in the matter of the West and copies it?
Or is there some modifications
that we would want to do?
I think the international
community on development aid
should also have lessons, you know.
There were so many
nitty-gritty details on aid
that could have made better
impact in the lives of people.
I hope those lessons are learned
and when we intervene in Afghanistan,
we re-intervene, or somewhere else,
we make better use of the
tax dollars that are paid.
Thank you. Rory?
- Well I think my final thing is,
be generous, be quick, have hope
and remember that when
you're talking about hope,
you're having hope in Afghans themselves.
And I think Dr. Orzala and Khalid
have been an extraordinary illustration
of why the international community
should be hopeful about Afghanistan.
We've had two individuals
speaking whose adult lives
really have been dominated
by the last 20 years.
And what you're seeing
in what you just witnessed is remember,
both Dr. Orzala and Khalid
have been through incredible trauma.
Their family, their friends,
their entire lives have
been turned upside down.
And yet you can see,
they are talking with incredible grace,
humility, thoughtfulness, objectivity.
They're not putting their
own self-interest forward,
they're trying to frame
constructive positive solutions
in an unbelievably difficult situation.
And so that should really give us hope
because that is of course
what people like me
love about Afghanistan,
that's why the international community
should believe in the
future of Afghanistan.
- I love that.
If we were all together in person
I know the audience would be applauding,
and I would as well.
So thank you so much to our panelists
for this conversation
on Afghanistan's future.
Again, this conversation
was part of a larger series,
the Yale Development Dialogues,
which we'll be continuing, so stay tuned.
And thanks so much to our
audience for tuning in.
We'll see you next time.